[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عصب وجوهر الحياه وعنصر الاساسي الماء
سواء كان نازلا من السماء يوم مستقرا على
الارض فهو احد اركان الكون فالسماوات خلقت
من بخاره والارض من زبده والعرب سكان
صحراء قاحله وجافه متراميه الاطراف واهل
تنقل وترحل طلبا لموارده ولاهميته ذكره
المولى في 57 موضعا وفي اربعين سوره وحثنا
المصطفى صلى الله عليه وسلم بعدم الاسراف
فيه وقال لا تسرف في الماء ولو كنت على
نهر جاري
الم ترى ان الماء يخبث طعمه وان كان لون
الماء ابيضا صافيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وللماء مجازات عند العرب يدل على العزه لا
تسقني ماء الحياه بذله بل فاستني بالعز
كاس الحنظلي وعلى قله الحياه اذا قل ماء
الوجه طل حياؤه ولا خير في وجه اذا قلماؤه
ويدل ايضا على الجمال فما زادني الواشون
الا صبابه ولا زادني الناهون الا تماديه
الم تعلمي يا عذبه الماء انني اظل اذا لم
اسقى ماءك صاديه
[موسيقى]